Georgia Maloney had invited the European
commission president here precisely to
see how much pressure Italy's
southernmost territory was under it
didn't take long for the Italian Prime
Minister also to be confronted with that
reality
Milani was confronted by a lamparduza
resident he pushed back when she talked
about investing more money insisting
instead they needed health peace and
dignity
they have that in common with the
thousands of mainly African arrivals
this week crammed into the Island's
Reception Center the two politicians
positioned a greatly more ordered scene
than what was on show just the previous
night the number reduced from Two and a
Half thousand to fifteen hundred as
transfers to the mainland continued
the European commission president had
prepared a 10-point plan for a response
to the crisis
it's a national Community we have
fulfilled it in the past and we will do
so today and in the future
but we will decide who comes to the
European Union and under what
circumstances and not the Smugglers and
traffickers along with more help
processing and monitoring arrivals and a
pledge to ensure legal roots for genuine
refugees Funderland spoke of increased
EU Naval activity without committing to
the kind of blockade Maloney was
speaking about as recently as Friday
however she continued to call for more
measures to stop the boats from leaving
the only way to address the problem
ensuring that the solution for one
nation does not mean creating a problem
for another nation is to tackle the
external Dimension and stop the illegal
departures of migrants a major part of
Georgia Maloney's message is that this
is a European border as well as an
Italian one requiring a European
solution but despite Ursula vandelayan's
10-point plan much remains unanswered as
to exactly what that solution is going
to be whether it will work and whether
it will be sufficient for those who
voted in Georgia Maloney as prime
minister
back at the reception Center we asked
Adu from Burkina Faso about the visit
and the politician's distinction between
refugees and economic migrants
we want the international protection
because there is no peace in our country
we are here because we don't have an
alternative we cross the sea to reach
Italy leaving our families behind why
should we do this if we really had some
peace in our country on Monday Georgie
Maloney plans to increase the maximum
detention period for those she calls
illegal migrants to 18 months the
European maximum but the motivation the
desperation to reach these Shores
remains undinned Harry Fawcett Al
Jazeera lampedusa
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera